No
Happy
birthday.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
a an abridgement of sorts of
authored by
may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala have mercy
upon him. May he lengthen and make
spacious for him his grave and may he
subhanahu wa ta'ala fill it with light
and reward him for what he had put forth
for the ummah of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and all of the scholars
of Islam and students of knowledge.
And so we are in the book of fasting
and the chapter regarding the pillars of
fasting. Before we go into the pillars,
let's do a little bit of review.
What are the
points of criteria or we could say the
conditions for fasting being obligatory
upon a person. How many are there?
Five. Good. Very good. Number one,
Muslim. Number two,
of of age of puberty or above. Number
three,
sanity.
Number four is health. Number five,
resident, not a traveler. And for a
female there's an additional and that is
that she is not upon on her menstrual
cycle or postpartum bleeding.
Now on to the pillars of fasting. How
many pillars for fasting?
Two pillars. The first one
intention.
The second
refraining
refraining from anything that will break
a person's fast from the break of dawn
until sunset.
Okay.
Now
before we get into the things that will
break a person's fast,
I want to mention one thing and that is
with respect to intention.
We mentioned that for an obligatory fast
for fasting Ramadan
vows
kafur
experation
for
you know the the various reasons a
person would fast but it is an
obligatory fast.
A person must have his intention set out
when
the night before the break of dawn. So
before the aden of fud. Now having said
this this intention is a pillar.
Now remember what we mentioned about
pillars that a condition is outside and
a pillar is part of the act of worship.
There's a reason why the scholars place
intention in fasting as a pillar and not
as a condition because in most instances
most acts of worship salah for instance.
The scholars mention they list intention
as being a condition of salah not a
pillar of salah. So what's the
difference here? What changed even in
this same book here?
If we go to the book of Salah and we
look at the chapter regarding the
conditions of salah, we find that one of
the conditions of salah is intention.
It's not one of the pillars. It's
counted as a condition.
We fast forward to the book of fasting
and intention now isn't a condition. It
is a pillar. The question is why? What
is the author telling us with this?
Well, what this means is that a person
must have that intention of fasting
throughout his day.
A person must have the intention of
fasting. They are refraining from eating
or drinking, refraining from anything
that will break their fast from the
break of dawn until the sun sets. And
that intention runs through the entirety
of the day. That's why it's counted as a
pillar. Why? Well, for instance, let's
say a person is fasting
and they decide
they're going to break their fast
right before the time before the time of
sunset say, "You know what? I'm going to
break my fast." But then as they go and
pop open the refrigerator or whatever it
is that they're going to break their
fast, their eye catches the clock and
they see there's only half an hour left,
right? They said half an hour. I might
as well just continue. They need to make
this day over.
Why? Because they intended to break
their fast.
This is why the scholars place intention
as a pillar of fasting whereas in salah
it is a condition of salah. There's a
difference there that the intention has
to be maintained throughout the day.
Whereas if a person were to intend its
opposite,
even if they don't break their fast
physically
with their intention, they have broken
their fast. And this is something that
could come up. for instance, let's
say someone has an allowance to break
his fast. Let's say someone is
traveling. Same scenario. They're
traveling. So they can break their fast
if they want, right? It's an obligatory
fast. It's Ramadan.
and they decide they're going to fast
and you know they start getting thirsty
or whatever they they decide I'm going
to break my fast right as they're
driving. So they pull over into the rest
stop. They put some money in the in the
soda machine. They grab a soda, grab a
snack. As they go to open it, their eye
catches the clock. There's only 20
minutes left.
They say there's only 20 minutes left. I
might as well finish it. Right? They
have already broken their fast because
the intention to break a person's fast
breaks a person's fast. That's why the
scholars place intention in the pillar
section of fasting and not in the
condition section.
That intention has to be maintained
throughout the day. Right? This is
important. Now, there is a difference
between contemplating breaking your fast
and having the set intention to break
your fast. What breaks your fast is a
set intention to break your fast. And
this is why we say, you know, he opens
the fridge or he takes the glass of
water, what have you. He has the
intention to break his fast. The the the
fact that he didn't is incidental,
but he had the intention to break his
fast.
That's different than, well, I'm going
to prepare myself to break my fast, but
I'm still unsure. Unsure doesn't break a
person's fast. It is only when they have
the solemn intention to break their
fast. At that moment they have broken
their fast. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
an allowance to break their fast,
traveler, illness, etc. They can break
their fast at any time they choose.
They can break their fast anytime they
choose. If they start the day fasting
and then they decide to break their fast
later, they have the allowance to do
that. However, they have to make the day
up. Same thing with the intention. The
person intends to break his fast 10 15
minutes before time and then doesn't,
they've already broken their fast. So,
they have to make that day up because
it's an obligatory fast. Now if it is a
if it is a fast that is a
meaning it is a
optional right so not Ramadan not making
up days from Ramadan not a kafar right
not something that is obligatory there's
many types of obligatory fasting let's
say a person is fasting for
a person is fasting fasting for ada
person is fasting a Monday or Thursday
person is fasting one of the three days
of each month or just any optional fast
they can continue their fast and
inshallah their fast is accepted and it
doesn't break by merely intention
because optional fasting has a little
bit different rules with respect to
intention than obligatory fasting Yes,
that's what it was. Okay. So, where do
we get this from? We might as well go
ahead and discuss this now.
And that is that
narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and his wives in general
narrated that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam would come at midday midday so
before and he would ask his wives do we
have anything to eat and if they said no
he would then say then I am fasting
right
he can't eat anyways there's nothing to
eat might as well fast now this is
midday he didn't have the solemn
intention to fast at the break of dawn.
This is an optional fast. The scholars
have cited this narration and others
it that optional fasting a person
can intend to fast at any time
throughout the day as long as they
haven't done anything that would
otherwise break their fast since the
break of dawn.
So, a person can't have breakfast and
then say, "I'm fasting,
an optional fast." Okay? They have to
have not eaten or drank anything or had
sexual activity, not done any of the
things that will break a person's fast
since the break of dawn. They can choose
to fast at any time throughout the day.
Some scholars say we need to stay within
the parameters of the narration and that
is before.
So before a person can intend to fast
after a person cannot because most of
the day has gone by. However, this
parameter is not necessarily the case.
Optional fasting a person may choose to
fast at any time throughout the day.
Right? if a person hasn't eaten or or
hasn't done anything that would break
their fast from the break of dawn and 10
minutes before me decides you know what
I haven't eaten or drank anything today
I haven't done anything that would have
broken my fast I'm going to intend this
to be fasting and
break my fast in 10 minutes is that
permissible yes this is permissible
inshallah this is acceptable a person
intends to break his fast during an
optional fast but then doesn't do they
need to make it up no they can continue
their fast and inshallah is acceptable
so intentions
with respect to optional fasting is less
strict is less stringent however with
obligatory fasting the intention must be
there coherent
and clear from the break of dawn on
until the sun sets uninterrupted.
Uninterrupted
meaning they have not when we say
interrupted meaning they have not had
the intention to oppose their fast.
[Silence]
Okay.
So going on into the pillars of fasting,
we can mention them very quickly and
then we will unpack them one by one
tomorrow inshallah. So the things that
will break a person's fast
are five things.
Some scholars mention them as six. Here
in this book, the author mentions them
as six, but we can say five because one
is very similar to the other and that is
right. So
five or if you wish six things will
break a person's fast.
six things. When we learn these things,
we know that anything aside from these
six
will not break a person's fast. Okay?
Anything outside of these six, if
they're not on this list, the fast is
correct.
All right? The first and second, eating
or drinking anything intentionally.
This is a very important a very
important stipulation and that is
eating or drinking anything
purposely.
Meaning a per a person knows that he's
fasting
and then proceeds to eat or drink
something. Right? This will break a
person's fast.
Eating or drinking anything
purposely
and we'll discuss these things in detail
tomorrow inshallah. We want to set
them out. I want them to I want these
things to be in your mind. This list
kind of turn it over in your mind. Let
it simmer on the back burner and then we
can unpack it in more detail tomorrow
inshallah. So we want to just plant the
seed today. So the first and second
eating or drinking anything
intentionally
that's one and two. Number three.
[Silence]
The third is
inducing
vomiting.
is that a person induces
That a person
does this vomiting on purpose. He makes
himself vomit.
Right? If a person were to just vomit,
they smell something, they think of
something, they get an upset stomach,
whatever it is, and they vomit. They're
ill, they're sick, they're feeling sick,
and they vomit. This will not break
their fast. A person making himself
vomit, right? Inducing vomiting. He
sticks his fingers in and makes himself
vomit. This will break a person's fast.
Now, this might sound strange to some
people. You say, you know, what are you
making yourself vomit for? Right? It's
like,
but no, this is actually one of the
prophetic remedies in the Sunnah.
One of the prophetic remedies in the
Sunnah
is to vomit. A person eats something
bad. A person, the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam made himself vomit on a
number of occasions. Abu Bakr,
others of the companions. This is part
of the prophetic medicine.
Number four and five or you could count
it as four is
ministration or postpartum. We
mentioned that postpartum bleeding.
We've mentioned before that
so menration and postpartum bleeding
they have the same rulings throughout
all of the Islamic legislation
except in three places
only in three instances
there's the the Islam Islam
differentiates between ministration and
postpartum.
Other than that, it's a rule of thumb
that menration and postpartum have the
same rulings across the board. Okay.
And number six, the sixth and final is
intercourse.
Intercourse. And intercourse has
parameters. It it can be quantified
what is intercourse, what is the
threshold of intercourse. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam identified
the threshold of intercourse
and intercourse purposely knowingly
during the day of Ramadan without an
allowance to break one's fast is a major
sin in Islam and it has one of the most
strict repercussions which is to fast
two consecutive months
Right. This is only matched by a
and
and accidental
killing killing some a Muslim by
accident. So this really shows you just
how serious this infraction is in Islam.
This is the sixth elim which is
intercourse. Now the author doesn't
stipulate amden.
He doesn't say intercourse purposely
he did with eating and drinking
he did with and we'll discuss that
issue inshallah when it comes up.
So six things or we could say five.
Let's list them very quickly. Number one
and two,
eating and drinking anything knowingly.
Three,
intentional vomiting, inducing vomiting.
Number four and five,
ministration and postpartum. Number six,
intercourse.
Very easy. Sheh, I got my arm cut off.
Does that break my fast? It's not on
this list. I pulled a tooth. Does this
break my fast? You look at the list.
It's not on the list, right? I have
blood drawn. Does it break my fast? It's
not on the list. A suppository. Does it
break my It's not on the list. Eye
drops. Does it break my It's not on the
list. This is why we learn the list,
right? And we will detail these tomorrow
inshallah. Yes.
nasal spray
which goes into is a very good question
which goes into eating and drinking
intentionally. Why?
Because the nose and the mouth both
empty to the throat.
And so a nasal spray,
, this is actually a type of prophetic
medicine as well to use, , black seed
and to drop it into the back of the
nasal and so forth. This will break a
person's fast. This is part of eating
and drinking intentionally because
eating and drinking doesn't necessarily
mean something that you chew, right? And
that's why we have to unpack these six
things tomorrow. But I want you to
memorize the list today. Six things.
Eating and drinking intentionally.
Self-induced vomiting. Four and five.
Ministration. Postpartum bleeding.
Number six. Alcourse.
for